hi everybody
thank you very much for attending this
webinar
my webinar is to focus on the drugging
effort
on ras uncle protein which
arguably the most notorious cancer
target
the term undruggable is somewhat
of an exaggeration and the more proper
term should be yet to be drugged
our experience teaches us that many
so-called undruggable targets
were eventually successfully
targeted and drugged because of major
advancement made
an understanding of biochemical and
biological properties
of these proteins and the availability
of structure
insights provided by x-ray
crystallography
and the nuclear magnetic resonance alike
today i would like to place my focus on
the rad story
after seeing so many scientists spending
decades of time
trying to find a drug that can inhibit
rest
and the cancers caused by the rest
i'm very happy to see the recent
progress
made in this area
cancer drugs have evolved since 1939
when charles higgins used synthetic
hormones
to treat prostate cancer the first
chemotherapy drug
mustin was used in 1942
followed by sydney farber's use of
anti-folate
to treat leukemia in subsequent years
chemotherapeutic drugs targeting dna
by alkylating agents
dna synthesis by nucleotide analogues
and microtubules by within christine
vinblasting and taxo
as well as anthracyclines targeted
at various cellular targets with
the pillars of for cancer treatment
the 1990s were marked by the targeted
therapy
revolution which
inhibits the tyrosine kinase activity of
bcr
able a fusion protein derived from the
philadelphia chromosome translocation
was invented and discovered to be
effective
against chronic model leukemia cml
and again fda approval on 2001.
the advantage of moral antibody
therapies
such as rituximab for treatment of
hematological malignancies
and approval of the aromatase inhibitor
and estrogen for breast cancer further
highlighted
the progress of the 1990s
and the years 2000 witnessed
further fda approval of monochrome
antibodies
most famously those targeting immune
checkpoint
ctl-4 and pt-1
underscoring remarkable advances in
immunotherapy
that include the use of dendritic
dendritic cell vaccines and heart rt
over the last two decades the treatment
of
tumor patients has been revolutionized
by the highly successful introduction of
normal targeted
therapies however despite
great improvements of survival rates
limitation due to tumor heterogeneity
primary and acquired resistance and
immune evasion
are still needed to be overcome
accordingly
ongoing clinical trials actively
explore the individualized use of small
molecule
and biologic drugs in new targeted
therapy combinations
based on patient parameters and tumor
biopsies
the molecular principles and drug
classes
that may hold promise for improved tumor
therapy combination
regimens including kinase inhibition
induction of apoptosis the inner damage
response
inhibition epigenetic reprogramming
telomerase inhibition and others
as listed on these slides
ras is the most frequently mutated gene
family
in kansas investigators
have sought an effective rash inhibitor
for well over 30 years the rice protein
includes three closely related
21 kilodalton iso forms they are
etcheras mras and k-ras
ras was initially identified in the
1960s
by harvey and kristen as a retroviral
uncle gene
when sarcomas were induced in rodents
from a meringue leukemogenic virus
preparation
there are two copies of k-rest namely
k-res1
and k-ras2 k-res1 is a pseudogene
and k-rest 2 is simply referred to as
k-ras k-ras is alternatively
spliced to form k-s-4 a and k-s-4-b
the term k-ras is generally used to
indicate krs-4b
various mutant forms of keras are now
identified
and are divided into three broad
categories
based on the mutated codon g12
at the code m12 g13
at codon 13 and q61
at codon 61.
it was found that somatic k-ras
mutations
are present in about 30 of all human
cancers
the prevalence of k-ras mutations
is about 30 in lung adenocarcinoma
and 5 in lung squamous cell carcinoma
g12c is the most common mutation subtype
g12c means glycine to sustain
mutation at codon 12. and
this g12c is accounting
for about 40 percent of all k ras
mutation
and followed by g12 v
in colorectal cancers k rise mutations
occur in about 30 to 40 percent of case
all cases g12d and g12v
are the two most common mutation
subtypes
the prevalence of k-ras mutations in
pancreatic carcinoma is the highest
showing well about 80
with g12d being the most common subtype
the ras protein is a membrane-bound
protein
with gtpas activity
and cycling between an inactive
gdp bar and an active
gtp bound form a common mechanism
of gtpa's deregulation in cancer
is the deregulated expression or
activity of their regulatory proteins
one being guarding nucleotide exchange
factors
show for gef
that promote formation of the active
gtp biostate and
another being gtpa's active
activating proteins show for gaps
that return the gtpas to its gtp
bound in active state
when bound to gtb ras
is switched on and activates
intracellular signaling pathway
including the myogen-activated protein
kinase
mapk and first fatigue
inositol three kinase pi3k pathway
which are critical for cell
proliferation
and angiogenesis mutated rest
is constitutively activated
and persistently turned on thereby
enhancing downstream signaling and
leading
to tumor genesis and tumor cell growth
the graph shows various approaches
trying to inhibit rest function
including membrane association
downstream effector
signaling metabolism autophagy
synthetic lethality and direct
inhibition
the direct inhibition approach made
some great progresses recently
for many years since early 1990
great pre-clinical and clinical efforts
were dedicated to inhibit the membrane
association of
rash protein rice proteins require
membrane association
for their biological activities
lipid modification of rash proteins
by a pharmaceutisopranoid
is an obligate step in that association
and is an enzymatic process
accordingly pharmaceuticals
inhibitors show for ftis
were developed as potential anti-rash
drugs
the lack of efficacy of ftis
as anti-cancer drug in clinical trials
was previously seen an indication that
walking rice membrane association was
a full approach to cancer treatment
however a deeper understanding of
rash modification and trafficking has
revealed that
this was a wrong conclusion in the
presence of
ftis press and unrest
become substrate for alternative
modification
called journal generation so
they can escape the inhibition
and they can still associate with
membrane and therefore still function
thus ftis fail
not because ras membrane association
isn't an effective approach but
because ftis failed to accomplish that
task
more recent efforts are being
re-initiated
to this approach
on this slide proteins are shown by
surface representation
with compounds and nucleotides shown as
stick models
each panel is colored to highlight
important surfaces
with switch 1 in blue color
switch to in pink color and
relevant interfaces color uniquely
in a express bind to
gdp mp which can be used
as a reference for orientation
in b switch to pocket in purple
of k rise g12c
bound to inhibitor amg
510 in c
switch 2 groove in purple bound to
inhibitory compound 2 c07
in d dca pocket
which is in teal color of rash g12d
bound to the inhibiting dcai
compound in e it shows
a sum of 7s which is sos
that we would talk about later
binding interservice in red of x-rays
in f it is the proposed hrs
dynamization interface in green
bound by ns1 model body which
is shown in gold in g reference
binding domain binding into
face in yellow of rash edge rest
some of these important rest interactive
structures
for dragging rash will be mentioned
later
let's clear us g-12c mutations only
account for
a proportion of k-ras mutations and
are primarily found in long
adenocarcinoma
to effectively inhibit the other common
krs mutations
came namely k-ras g12 d
and k-rash g-10v different approaches
are needed as these mutants
lack reactive cysteine in
active site
k-ras gene is essential for mouse
embryonic development whereas
enrage and hrs are dispensable
if humans are similar to this regard
the requirement for k-rest creates
toxicity concerns when targeting the
wild-type
clearance protein the field of
ras inhibitors pioneered by kevan shokak
and colleagues has focused on
covalent inhibition of k-ras
g12c only
the inherently reactive nature of
cysteine
which is found at codon 12 of krxg12c
can be utilized to create covalent
small molecular inhibitors importantly
wild-type t-rex lacks sustain
in the active site so k-ras
g12c can be specifically inhibited
with this approach from another angle
initial efforts to block gef
activity to all arrest identify
a small molecule the bound k rash
between
switch 1 and switch 2. thereby
inhibiting sos binding and so's
and sos mediated nucleotide exchange
somehow the field then
shifted focus and tried to find small
molecular inhibitor
of sos one group
identified a small molecule inhibitor
bay293
that inhibited the sos ras
interaction at nanomolar level
however bay 293
weekly inhibited keras mutant cell
proliferation
but more potently inhibited
proliferation of
wild-type keras cells
currently a later identified sos1
inhibitor bi1701963
is progressing in clinical trials
in 2013 kevin schoke
and colleagues developed the first
series of small molecules
to buy k-ras g12c the most potent of
which is compound 12.
modification of the linker and
hydrophobic binding pocket led to the
development
of a more potent and cellular active
compound
ars a53
further improvement such as the
introduction of
a quinoxylin based series and the
fluorophenol
hydrophobic binding moiety enhanced
the potency and pharmacological
properties
and led to the development of ars-1620
using an alternative orientation of h95
in the switch to pocket allow the
addition of
aromatic rings to enhance the protein
protein interaction
with k-rash g12c
leading to the development of amg 510
structure-based drug design approaches
and optimization later led to the
development of
mr tx a4
kevlar shortcast lab at the ucsf
developed the first series of compounds
to irreversibly target krs g12c
this compounds bound krs
g12c in the gdp bound state
blocked sos catalyzed nucleotide
exchange and blocked k-ras g2c
association with rafts this compound
only bound to kvf's g12c
associated in the gdp bound state
and therefore required ras
kras g12c to first undergo
gtp hydrolysis
about 75 percent of k-ras g12c
is gtp bound in a steady state
but krs g12c has the highest
level of intrinsic gtpa's activity
among the common oncogenic mutations
and therefore is vulnerable to covalent
attack since
mutations in k rise other than
g12c have a lower rate of intrinsic gdp
hydrolysis
it's unclear whether targeting the
switch
2 pocket through a similar approach
in this other mutant form will be
successful
the company called wellspring
biosciences
later showed that when given to mice
implanted with k-rest
carrying human tumors an improved
version of shortcuts molecule shrank
the tumor growth
engines amg 510
and marathi's mrtx
a49 act in a similar manner
both by in the switch to pocket
and form specific covalent attachment
to the mutant system and locked the
protein
in the inactive conformation
here comes a summary of the non-clinical
efficacy results
from amg 510
and mrtx a49
they both effectively inhibited
cell growth against a wide range
of cancer cell lines
in both two-dimensional and
three-dimensional
cultures the inhibition was
observed in the majority of k-ras g12c
mutant cells specifically
however both inhibitors show a range of
ic50
suggesting that factors other than
krs g12c expression
contribute to inhibitor sensitivity
both inhibitors induced those dependent
reduction of tumor growth
in mice bearing krs
g12c mutant patient derived xenografts
from several cancer types
in combination egfr
and her2 inhibitor
ship 2 inhibitor mtor
inhibitor and the cdk4
and cdk6 inhibitors all
improve the response of krs-22c mutant
xenographs
to mrtx849
durable cures were obtained in most of
the
test syngenetic ct 26
tumor bearing mice after a amg
510 treatment and the effect
depends on the presence of t cells
the combination with pd1 immune
checkpoint inhibition
enhance single agent treatment
the clinical progress of the kras g12c
inhibitors is quite promising
by far amg 510
mrtx 849 jnj
746 99157
which is ars 3248
and ly3499446
entered clinical trials in 2019
and early results are as following
half of 13 amg 510
treated lung cancer patient show
regression
and half of six
mrt a49 lung cancer patient
showed shrank tumors as well as
one of four colon cancer patients
above are reported
in 2019 and below
are data reported
in uh asco in may
2020 three of 42 available
amg 510 treated colorectal cancer
patients
at 960 milligram show partial responses
and another 29 shows stabilized diseases
3 of 22 available amg 510
treated other solid tumor patients
achieve
partial responses and another 13 has
stable diseases
of whom three pancreatic cancer patients
show 30 tumor shrinkage
overall we are seeing good responses
and the efficacy in
lung cancer patient seems better than
the other cancer patients
as the field moves forward with the
clinical trials of
ras t12c inhibitors there are several
points
to bear in mind as follows
since the covalent inhibitors discussed
above
require k-ras g12c to be in a gtp-bound
state
resistant mutation could arise in g12c
that disable the gtpa's activity
or to promote the guardian exchange of
gdp for gtp
however recently molecules
have been discovered that by both the
gdp
bound and gtp bound states of
k-ras this molecules by the new groove
which is switch 2 groove which is
adjacent to the switch to pocket
but away from the nucleotide binding
site
this discovery highlights the dynamic
nature of the switch to pocket and
provides
proof of concept evidence that both
nucleotide binding states of ras can be
targeted
with inhibitors which is a good news
more durable disease control in the
non-smoking lung carcinoma cohort may be
partly
related to higher egfr expression
in colorectal cancer patient versus
non-smoking lung carcinoma patients
and blocking krs g12c
may lead to compensatory phosphorylation
of egfr
this in turn activating the mac
pathway the krf
g12c may not be dominant driver
in colorectal cancer or other pathways
such as wind and egfr
mediate oncogenic signaling beyond
k-ras vertical blockade
of both egfr and kras to achieve
optimal clinical benefit may be
necessary
earlier we have talked about the
strategy
of panerai's inhibition by binding to
sos1 bearinger ingelheim's
bi1701963
inhibits krs by binding to sos 1
which activates k-ras through the
exchange of k
the raspbian gdp for gtp
the selective inhibition of sos 1 allows
k-ras blockade irrespective of k-rest
mutation type
pre-clinical data have shown that the
pan-k-ras
inhibitor blocks tumor groups for many
tested
g12 and g13 krs gene mutations
and the compound is selective for cancer
cell line with mutations
in the k-ras gene the combination
of the bi compound with the mac
inhibitor
demonstrated a strong impact
on k-ray signaling and resulted in
increased anti-tumor activity
based on dual pathway blockade and
complementary mechanism of actions
clinical trials of bi1701963
as a single agent or in combination with
traumatic has already been started
protect proteolysis targeting chimera
is a novel approach to turn on druggable
to druggable recently craig cruz
and team reported a first-in-class
development
of a k-ras g-12c degrader
lc2 lc2 combines
the use of mrtx849
as warhead and vhl
e3 ligase as effector
in the panel of non-small cell lung
casino line
k-ras g12c proteins can be
specifically and efficiently degraded
many researchers are studying the protac
approaches
using various warheads different
effectors
and different intermediate linkers
more of this approach will be discussed
at a fewer slides later
ken palmer is a contract research
organization
we work as an extension of our clients
r d division to advance our clients drug
discovery projects
we have over 2 000 scientists to form
six major divisions and they are
biology and pharmacology the mpk
chemistry discovery chemistry cmc
biologics discovery and biologic cnc
we have broad experience in contributing
to our partners
in developing therapeutic
against wide variety of disease targets
in search for k-ras inhibitors
we have set up several platforms
including
k-ras g12c g12d
g12v and sos inhibition
and we have established multiple
aces for k-ras inhibitors screening
we can use different aces for macula
for mechanism studies for example
different binding pockets using amg
510 as a positive control
here we show its inhibition to gl
g12c only in contrast
b293 show inhibition to keras wildtype
and mutant proteins by inhibiting
sos1 and we are currently establishing
more
rest inhibition asics
we take pride to have more than 800 well
annotated and validated cancer cell
lines
in our collection and we have a panel of
2d and 3d cellular ac's available
on this page at the left side it shows
amg 510 was tested
against three non-small cell lung
carcinoma cell lines
in a 2d cell title glow a6
in which amg 510
showed good potencies against
k-ras g12c mutated ncih35a
and ncih2122 cells
while the ras wild-type ncih1299 cells
were clearly more resistant
at the right-hand side amg 510
was tested in 3d metrogel aces
at both shorter and longer incubation
terms
against ncih35a cells
and again strong potency
was observed
we utilize a variety of methodologies
for example ihc facts
massback to characterize biomarker
changes
during tumor progression this slide
shows a comparison of downstream
pathway marker changes in the western
blot asap
when ncih35a cells
were treated with amg 510
and other compounds the results
showed that amg 510
at the left panel potently
and those dependently inhibited the
phosphorylation of erc
while the other two compounds were not
able to do so
we use our 800 well characterized
cell lines to set up target validation
proliferation and functional aces
we also utilize these cellulites
to establish subcutaneous and orthotopic
xenograft models established models
containing various krs mutation
such as g12a g12c
g12d g12s
g12v and others are shown
in the tables on this page some of them
have been validated by testing against
amg 510
this slide shows studies we did
to test combination of compounds
in development with amg 510
in two k-ras g12c xenograph models
of ncih2122
and ncih35a
both non-smosceolong carcinomas
six to eight weeks old female bob c
new mice were used at 10 miles per group
amg 510 at 100 meg per kit
for single agent and 30 meg per kit
for combo was dosed orally
twice a day daily both
single agent and those dependent
efficacy
combination results were demonstrated
amg 510 show potent
single agent and combination efficacy
in chem partner our biology and
pharmacology department
has strong in vitro biology
cell biology and in vivo pharmacology
efforts
through the dedication of more than 260
scientists
we contribute extensively from target
validation
head filing lead optimization
candidate characterization to ind filing
in the drug r d processes
as mentioned earlier protect is one of
the approaches
we can use to drug oncogenic rats
protects and related molecules that
induce
targeted protein degradation by the
ubiquitin
proteosome system represents a new
therapeutic modality
and are the focus of great interest
protects are by functional small
molecules
that simultaneously bind to a target
protein
and the e3 ubiquitin ligase
thereby causing ubiquitination
and the degradation of the target
protein
the ability of protects to degrade
proteins
regardless of their functions make this
approach highly attractive particularly
for those targets for which available
compounds
that bind to a given target without
inhibiting
is a kit activity degradation of the
target proteins
by protects is also suitable for targets
that overcome the effect of inhibitors
by overexpression
ubiquitination of proteins
is carried out by a cascade of three
enzymes
this cycle can be repeated to generate a
polyurethane chain
that directs a substrate for degradation
at the proteasome within this cascade
e3 ligases are unique in their role of
dictating target specificity
we have implemented aces along the
cascade
to validate all steps from e1
activity assays e2 activity assays
e3 activity assays for protests
e3 activity aces for inhibitors
cell based asap and also d
your pivoting activity assays
we have established multiple a6
for protag activity evaluation
the left two graphs depict a chemical
ace
and the graphs at the right are two
cell-based acets
we have ternary complex formation asap
tcfa for protect binding
we have enzyme activity assays for
target protein imbibination
measurement we also have western
and eliza for cell-based aces
in vivo pk pd efficacy correlation
is extremely important for decision
making before moving a drug candidate
forward for safety evaluation
in addition to a complete platform
of in vitro and cell-based target
validation
moa and potency ace
chem partner has a complete in vivo
pharmacology platform
which encompass oncology models
ranging from more than 30 genetic
more than 250 cell line derived
xenograft
500 patient derives xenograft
to full human antigen knocking models
to support both small molecule
biologic and gene cell therapies
we have conducted thousands of
individual studies
in our a-lac accredited and
overall approved spf
animal facilities
as noted earlier oncogenic rats
can activate downstream proliferation
cascades
and inhibit immune surveillance
mechanisms
to promote tumor progression both
memkinase inhibitor pi3 kinase
inhibitors
and immune checkpoint regulators
are being utilized to be combined with
ras
inhibitors to maximize tumor therapeutic
effects
here i would like to present to you an
interesting
case study while we were evaluating a
pi3
kinase delta inhibitor we found out that
this compound showed much better
efficacy
in genetic model than xenograft models
well we tested this cinginate
tumor 41 in immunocompromised mice
the efficacy dramatically reduced
we then show as putin effects of the
compound
in another syngenetic model ct 26
with many mice demonstrated complete
regression
and high those levels
the test inhibitor also was shown
synergized when combined with anti-ptl1
antibody
many months later when we re-challenge
the in remission mice with
ct-26 mouse colon cancer
cells the challenging cells
failed to grow a
non-related tumor cell line 820
grow robustly the results
indicated that the efficacy of the
inhibitor
was immuno competency related
and was immune memory related
we then analyze xvivo with facts
the immune cells we isolated from tumors
and spleens of the mice in study
we found out the suppressive t-rex cells
infiltration
was inhibited in tumors by the test
inhibitor while the til
was not affected in the spleen
therefore we were able to show
that the compound was not only
inhibiting tumor growth
as an inhibitor of pi3 k
delta but also an immune regulator
currently this pi3k
delta compound is progressing really
well
in clinical trials with
so many similar features i sincerely
hope
the rest inhibitor currently
in clinical trials do really well
for the patients
many many scientists have been working
very hard
for almost 40 years to develop
effective therapeutics to inhibit
oncogenic rest
lack of success over the long years
made ras a very notorious undruggable
target
it is very exciting to witness several
breakthroughs
at different fronts in conquering this
enemy
we must learn from prior success
and failures to optimize drug design
develop new therapeutic approaches
and refine how patients are matched
to treatments at present
direct inhibition of mutant rats
provides
the best therapeutic approach for rest
activating cancers
therapies that target rest activating
pathways
or rest effective pathways could be
combined with
direct rest inhibitors immune checkpoint
inhibitors
or t-cell targeting approaches to treat
rash mutant tumors ken partner
has rich experience and strong
capabilities
to contribute to oncology drug discovery
and development we sincerely look
forward
to collaborating with future partners
thank you all very much for sharing your
precious time
to attend this webinar it will be my
pleasure
to entertain any question